getting buffoons like adam kinzinger  sitting in his office making bellicose  noises on social media just the other  day kinzinger posted images on twitter  of ukrainian air ace called the ghost of  kiev he downed russian migs left and  right  well turns out the whole thing was a  hoax but of course adam kinsar had no  idea because he knows nothing quote the  ghost of kiev has a name and he has  absolutely owned the russian air force  he tweeted imagine a sitting member of  congress tweeting about a war like it's  a cable news site he absolutely owned  the russian air force really  get some respect people are dying  buffoon  kinzinger then attached an obviously  photoshopped image of the comedian sam  hyde sitting in the cockpit of a fighter  jet sam hyde for the record is not  ukrainian fighter ace he is once again a  comedian  that was adam kinzinger these are the  people pushing us toward a new world war  so at the very least let's pause and  think this through